to wrap up this lesson I really want you
to think about what you've learned and
what you might do next
metrics from user behavior and feedback
from users are critical if you want to
improve the product and forge ahead as
you reflect on data you may want to plan
additional design sprints we actually
did this at Udacity to rethink student
support a design sprint can be a great
way to make changes to the product you
might also discover that you've chosen a
poor metric or that you're not retaining
users if so then you might want to
rethink your key metrics or alter the
original idea ultimately it's up to you
to iterate on a product or reimagine a
product so that way you build something
users love